saint cloud
et ça sent la poudre salle au
foyer city
le magic ne pas s'y mettre
ils sont là depuis 40 ou 50 ans beaucoup
d'entre eux vivent hot en vendant ce
qu'ils peuvent
chez ahmed s'épiler gant de toilette un
petit business qui lui rapporte 5 à 10
euros par jour
arrivé en france en 64 il a travaillé
sur des chantiers
la vérité moins cher
voilà
au mieux le magasin un mag a déjà formé
manas
dans le quartier tous les commerçants
connaissent leurs difficultés à boucler
les fins de mois ces vieux travailleurs
ont un peu tous la même histoire
ils avaient des patrons qu'il faisait
travailler soit disant déclaré n'hésitez
pas déclarés depuis ce fils de ben est
exercée par la caisse de retraite ça
fait qu'une fois car au bout de trente
ans par alger introduire la timone
demandé à la retraite monsieur vous avez
pas trop utiliser
les patrons fils ou à l'époque ces
listes et puisque tu te pas hésité en
fait à la main mais non alors le type il
a trimé trimer mais la retraite touchés
venir quand il va à la caisse de
retraite nous sommes des tisanes et qui
s'adapte
toutes ces années ces hommes ont cru en
la france depuis toujours marseille
c'est la porte d'entrée des jeunes
d'afrique du nord
en 1954 ils n'étaient que deux cent
cinquante mille établis en france un
chiffre qui va presque tripler à la fin
des années 60 à l'époque il y avait du
travail ils étaient les bienvenus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui une partie de ces hommes vit
toujours à quelques centaines de mètres
du port où ils ont débarqué dans le
quartier de belsunce
l'endroit est en pleine rénovation
c'est ici qu'ils ont vécu dans le
provisoire dans l'idée de retourner un
jour au pays vieillir près de leur
famille
mais le retour est plus difficile que
prévu ils vivent toujours dans les mêmes
hôtels meublés
des hôtels pas chers aux enseignes un
peu trompeuse au confort très incertain
c'est dans un de ces hôtels meublés que
nous avons rencontré monsieur moix iba
il a 66 ans il est algérien et vit dans
cette petite chambre depuis 30 ans sans
chauffage
il est arrivé en 1969 et il a même gardé
le papier qu'il a présentée aux
douaniers français le jour de son
arrivée
spécial
as
à l'époque il n'y avait pas de quotas il
n'était pas question d'immigration
choisie
l'arrivée de jeunes travailleurs
algériens était même prévue par les
accords d'evian entre la france et
l'algérie il suffisait aux candidats
d'être en bonne santé pour obtenir le
tampon d'entrée
c'est la france qui demande des
travailleurs à ses passes pas la gérer
un mois j'ai passé avec la visite milité
avec la visite hector français j'ai pas
ce message qui passe avec le gps ça va
aussi babol des basses laissant télé
d'ici bon après et va saigner vous voyez
avec le préfecture
de la loire kahn est sidérante la
chambre l'effroyable sauvage et rien du
tout et commentateurs maladie et oui et
matt voyez rabat voyez rien du tout
la plupart des hôtels meublés du
quartier sont complètement délabré
c'est ce que vient constater ce jour-là
un huissier envoyé par le tribunal de
marseille il vient faire un état des
lieux pour savoir si cet immeuble doit
être réhabilité
trois très vieux messieurs se partagent
ces toilettes
à tous les étages c'est le même un
confort
mauricien convocation n'a pas tous les
points d'eau avec de l'eau froide n'y a
pas d'eau chaude donc ici même chose
deux équipements sanitaires n'est pas
aux normes et on n'a pas de chauffage sa
surface et la
préserver j'ai mis le chauffage
voilà la chambre d'un des locataires
puis dans une chambre dans un réduit que
ce monsieur occupe depuis le matin
[Musique]
ça vous arrive souvent de moi ce type de
logement
malheureusement oui assez régulièrement
dans le centre ville de marseille
et avec des populations retraités parce
que ça vous arrive et que en majeure
partie des populations retraités actifs
d'origine
ensuite les autres champs
en fait tout l'immeuble est un immense
courants d'air parcouru par les rats et
rongé par les moisissures
parce que je cachais display
non pas
comme ça je vais en prendre un cliché
voilà
et on a une chance une surface deux
mètres cinquante comme remettre 85 au
total six mètres carrés
crois qu'à l'heure actuelle les cellules
dans les établissements financiers ni
d'un cias ont de 6 mètres carrés je
crois savoir
ses hommes ne se sont jamais révolter
contre leurs conditions de vie ici pas
plus qu'au travail
monsieur moix iba se rappelle de ses
années sur les chantiers j'ai pas aller
la mer détour par cabaye a pas de
masquer rien dit toi vas naoui mena ya
les masques et où il y avait d'une part
et le masque d'une paille rien dit ou la
base
de travail comme ça la mer des rentes
des retours
et oui la musique à varanasi bon le
moenner travailleurs menacés bon y aller
avant moi je travaille des traces magie
magelio régime enjeux de la lauter
mais maintenant gmail à l'apparat qu'il
ya du chauffage elle est tout
comme déclare comme des canards à
aujourd'hui à la retraite monsieur moi
il va être toujours déchirée entre ces
deux pays sa femme et ses six enfants
vivant en algérie pendant 37 ans il a dû
se contenter de les voir grandir sur des
photos et aujourd'hui ça continue lui
doit rester en france pour bénéficier de
ses droits sa retraite la sécurité
sociale de tout ce qu'il a acquis en
travaillant
et seydoux m'a trop mal à l'algérie site
où elle est toujours toujours eh oui
[Musique]
mais ces allers-retours cost aujourd'hui
beaucoup de soucis à ses vieux retraité
de marseille
à cheval entre deux pays l'équilibré
précaire
d'autant que de plus en plus ils ont le
sentiment qu'on leur demande de choisir
c'est dans un petit restaurant du
quartier de belsunce que nous avons
rencontré monsieur besnéhard il a 72 ans
dont 45 entre l'algérie et la france
[Musique]
la balle
roumanie
est tout seul toujours
bateau
depuis six mois le vieux monsieur à des
tracas administratifs d'un nouveau genre
une des seules personnes qui tentent de
l'aider c'est nordine abouakil il anime
une association qui défend les retraités
célibataires du quartier centre ville
pour tous
nordine se bat pour faire rénover des
hôtels et empêcher des expulsions mais
aujourd'hui mohamed besnéhard lui a
demandé de venir pour autre chose ses
revenus et ses droits sociaux sont
menacés
les temps ont bien changé depuis
l'époque où le vieux monsieur rêvait
d'une terre de bienveillance et de
prospérité
une attaque en tête lobée raffarin
déroule à quand
oui when her bien oui les idées et des
dans la tête il dormait avec la france
c'est une manière de dire je rêvais avec
la france d'ailleurs tout à fait ça
quand müller ou là là
là bas sera t elle je travaille et il
dit on qui travaillé et il dit la baisse
du patron et
il a toujours eu des périodes longues
chez des patrons
parce que tant qu'ils travaillaient ils
étaient bien
l'idée que les périodes de chômage était
très très réduite c'est à dire que il
quittait un employeur lundi vendredi
lents trouver un autre il touche
aujourd'hui une retraite de 500 euros
toute cette vie de travail est résumé
dans ce sac feuilles de paye feuille
d'impôts il a tout conservé
précieusement
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui aux
yeux du fisc le vieux monsieur ne
passerait pas suffisamment de temps à
marseille pour être considéré comme un
résident français à cause de ces
fameuses aller retour pour aller voir sa
famille comme le font tous les chibanis
il pourrait perdre ses droits
ça c'est la vie 3 la déclaration 2003 et
la vie 2003 par contre ici on a la
déclaration 2004 que monsieur a reçu
préimprimés de la part de services
fiscaux on l'a invité à remplir cette
déclaration il a rempli et rendu en
temps et en heure parce que là je vois
24 mars et au jour d'aujourd'hui il fait
partie de ces très nombreux retraités du
quartier à qui on refuse la vis fiscal
et qu'est ce que ça peut avoir comme
conséquence pour lui de ne pas avoir
l'avis fiscal en fait ce monsieur peut
très bien
se voir priver de toutes les aides qui
sont soumises à conditions de revenus le
minimum vieillesse de mener mon
vieillesse l'aide au logement
la gratuité des bus pour les personnes
de plus de 65 ans sont une condition de
revenus toutes ces conditions
perdu dans ses papiers monsieur bénard
est inquiet il n'est pas sûr de
continuer à bénéficier de la totalité de
ses droits sociaux
nordine lui s'interroge est ce une façon
de chasser ces gens du centre ville en
rénovation est ce une façon de les
renvoyer dans leur pays
en
tous les cas dans le centre de marseille
ils sont quatre mille à vivre dans la
même incertitude
ils ont coutume de se retrouver ici
place des oubliés comme ils disent pour
prendre le soleil ou le café
pour être résident français ces
retraités doivent donc passer six mois
et un jour en france encore faut-il
arriver à le prouver au fisc et dans
cette vie d'aller retour c'est un
véritable casse tête
ce petit monsieur mohamed est dans ce
cas plusieurs personnes ont pris fait et
cause pour lui parce qu'il lui manque le
fameux à vis fiscal il vient de se voir
supprimer son minimum vieillesse la
moitié de ses revenus
avec le vieux monsieur le petit groupe
de marseillais seront à l'hôtel des
impôts pour le soutenir dans ses
démarches
mohamed à ses quittances de loyer il a
tous ses papiers pourtant apparemment ça
ne suffit pas
[Musique]
l'employé du fisc ne lui fait pas
confiance et lui réclame son ancien
passeport pour vérifier ces dates
d'entrée et sortie en france l'année
précédente alors qu'il a renouvelé vous
savez pertinemment que quand celui-là
l'ancien passeport garder le gard et les
laiteries professionnels à marseille
aussi nous détruit beaucoup d'objets le
confort grâce à monsieur qui est ce
monsieur qui est retraité à l'heure
actuelle pourquoi on luttera cassé ma
vie
mohamed repart sans avoir eu gain de
cause
il a 80 ans 40 ans de travail en france
et depuis ce mois-ci 400 euros par mois
pour vivre